ah
[Música]
en tiempos de aislamiento y
distanciamiento social muchos brasileños
se han rendido la bicicleta conducción
para el transporte público pero también
para realizar una actividad física según
una encuesta realizada por la asociación
brasileña de la industria de la
bicicleta en julio de este año en el
punto álgido de la pandemia en el país
en las ventas del sector aumentaron un
118 por ciento en comparación con el
mismo período del año anterior pero
también hubo un gran boom en el mercado
de las bicicletas eléctricas el sector
creció 34 por ciento en comparación con
los últimos tres años la encuesta
explica que hubo un mayor uso de las
bicicletas en las capitales brasileñas
ya que la población lo trató de evitar
grandes aglomeraciones en el transporte
público y de adaptarse a las medidas de
distanciamiento social
[Música]
a raíz de la pandemia se ha incrementado
el número de ciclistas en londres que
usa la bicicleta para transportarse o
ejercitarse además el gobierno ha
ampliado las ciclovías hacia el centro
de londres con el fin de incentivar el
uso de la bicicleta que es 100%
ecológico además de seguro en época de
pandemia en medio de nuevas
restricciones para sociabilizar el
gobierno permite a grupos de ciclistas
de un máximo de seis salir a andar en
bicicleta lo cual es muy importante ya
que está prohibida
socializar entre amigos en pocos
restaurantes y en casas además el
productor más grande de bicicletas en el
reino unido- brompton anunció que se han
quintuplicado las ventas en línea en los
últimos meses mientras tanto los
esquemas de rentas de bicicletas han
sido un éxito desde 2010 y se estima que
ha habido 93 millones de rentas en la
última década
[Música]
la bicicleta es una de las grandes
ganadoras de la pandemia para evitar las
multitudes en el transporte público
miles de franceses han optado por
utilizar la bicicleta ya sea por ejemplo
de servicio público o personal ya que
además hay un bono que está otorgando el
gobierno por 50 euros para quienes
necesitan reparar sus bicicletas además
de esto son varias ya las ciudades que
dan unos subsidios de entre 100 a 400
euros por la compra de bicicletas en
especial eléctricas todo esto viene
acompañado también de más vías para las
bicicletas después del confinamiento en
mayo se crearon lo que se conocen como
corona pistas o corona vías allí donde
no había ciclorrutas pues se habilitaron
vías que eran antes para los automóviles
y que ahora lo son exclusivamente para
las bicicletas el ministerio de
transporte calcula que hay unos 500
kilómetros de esto uno de los ejemplos
de estas medidas es a parís que ha
estrenado desde el mes de mayo 50
kilómetros de cicloruta y donde el uso
de las bicicletas ha aumentado en un año
en 67%
[Música]
miles de personas